hey guys big shout-out to Caleb in the
team we're turning around content real
quick
today this Friday I just did a four DS
at Vayner there was a ton of great
content they decided to turn it quick
I made an intro I hope you enjoy this
episode this is more LinkedIn business
some business this is not motivating you
this is business talk enjoy this
business talk thank you all for being
here let's actually let's go backwards
sorry brother
let's go right into it what can I answer
for you so for us in these smaller
markets you have CNC markets yeah of our
customers are rural
yes they're in the country I know I'll
do this to be independent get away from
the utility company [ __ ] the man all
that kind of stuff so it's been
interesting for us because in those in
those markets it's it's easier easy for
us to get in front of those individuals
we and it's all about it's all about
cost so in this part of the country
where we are Arkansas Missouri Kansas
there's no save the world Go Green it's
not like a Berkeley or Seattle where
they're totally under seasons it's 100
percent will this save me money above
and beyond stay with the utility company
and so for us that's that's really what
drives it so as we move into the towns
or or as the process plays out I mean
you know I don't know the business one
that I assume once you put the panels on
you know it's hard to unwind and move to
somebody else you know here but but
price price is an incredible thing to
play on sure I built wine my brand price
right price is incredible to play on I
think the question you always have to
ask yourself with price is can somebody
come along with bigger pockets and be
you on price you know where everybody
this is the reason Walmart destroyed
Kmart and Bradley's and Kaldor and those
guys destroyed Woolworths and when you
were in the price game you only have a
moment in time right that's right so for
us and to your point if you want to
expand there'll be other creative
pillars you'll have to play on that's
exactly right so as we try to get into
not necessarily urban but just into the
neighborhoods themselves like into town
right solar adoption is so low and
part of the country it's not like being
in a Phoenix or a Vegas Irish ala Forney
we see panels everywhere we've had a
difficult time breaking into the towns
breaking into the neighborhoods breaking
into the 300 400 500 thousand dollar
homes rather than someone out in the
country that you know they buy a solar
system for 30 grand but their house is
worth 120 right so it's it's trying to
craft and create our marketing and our
message to break into a different group
of people and talk to them about the
benefits that are for them and it's just
something it's just something we haven't
completely tackled and figured out yet
have you tried do we have to have a
certain extent we've talked about
there's a 30% federal tax credit that
you can take so we've tried to go into a
different demographic and saying hey you
want the best investment of the year do
you want the biggest tax break that you
could take average tax credits of 8,000
we've tried you know marketing more
along those messages of saying hey maybe
not so much saving saving savings but
let's talk about this from an investment
standpoint let's talk about this from a
long-term standpoint and why you want to
do it but any rhetoric or how many how
many different creative so you said you
built it on Facebook then you expanded
that's right when you one on Facebook
how many different creatives pieces of
creative a video a picture a you know
did you have in that execution
you'd probably at this point a couple of
dozen all video ads of me 2 to 3 minutes
long did you know educate educate
educate if you want to find out more if
you found this intriguing click below
we'll reach out and do a free energy
consultation and so what about for the
three to four hundred thousand yeah how
many different pieces are creative we
pretty much did the same thing across
the board and so the same amount but
different messages no not necessarily
different message but less we thought we
would do different messages to an extent
but we would serve them to everybody
that's the problem okay
different message different audience the
end right like anything in life like you
enough of a scale of a psychographic or
demographic that it's worth your time to
make the creative right and as many as
you can like literally the best way to
sell to me on instagram is to make a New
York Jets reference that's the truth
it's my actual religion I will pick Jets
over everything family religion and
money Jets over everything it's a truth
now that's not a lot of people so like
betting the farm on jet bands is
probably not the right move but I'll
tell you that what you need to do first
of all here this is gonna be the answer
for all of you everybody should take
away from this
there's the written word there's
pictures and there's video and then
there's what you say with those things
and then who you target when you get
great at that everything changes the
Vayner the company's going through a big
transformation a new kind of strategic
pillar base didn't you guys you guys saw
the post I made the Gary Vee content
model the 88 page deck did you hit your
guy's radar if it didn't you should see
it it's a very like it's probably the
most love I've ever gotten from the
internet because I think everybody
deeply understood that I could have that
people not like not me but people like
me would charge 1500 bucks for that
ebook and destroy it
I highly recommend you look at it but it
is the answer to a question like if you
live in Kansas City like look if you're
a 45 year old I'll give you an example
I'll give you a great example because
the hat you're wearing if you're
targeting people in Missouri a higher
net worth that are of and you target 42
to 63 year olds and you make a reference
to the 85 World Series it's going to
work make sense and if you can if you
and if you layer Cardinal fans and say
one thing or if you layer
Royals it's either that was the greatest
or that was some [ __ ] right
it's striking emotion to capture
people's attention right for example
when you make videos and you're lucky
you're using yourself and you're looking
in there and you're like
Fort Worth Texas I've got to tell you
cool let's film again Kansas City
Missouri like and then you run it
against that you know somebody from
Scottish or you know Wales background
versus an American or versus you're
saying yourself you're tapped out on
what you've got we got to go younger
getting four influences that are cool to
actually wear that to start the process
of getting 22 year olds to even consider
it because right now the consideration
is that's well you're not gonna run that
ad against a 68 year old Scotland
Scottish boy you're gonna run it again
you know and so like it's it's super
important like I'm already happy that
you a dozen or dozens which is already
way further along than most but it
misses the mark I literally think that
you should have four to eight thousand
pieces of content between written word
audio and video and running a hundred
dollar ad against it versus a thousand
dollar ad against twelve it's reverse
got it yeah I want you to pay more for
your CPMs because it's more expensive
when you go more narrow but you're
actually converting on what the [ __ ] you
care about I'm thrilled that we're
paying $22 to get somebody to buy this
because the math works right but
marketing companies Vayner itself others
people that are they want it to be $7
CPM is now 22 because that seems right
but then it doesn't play out because it
didn't mean as much to them right right
so even hearing your for demos like
every one of those demos needs its own
creative pillars and then within it
psycho and demographics there's a big
difference between the stage mom and the
actual girl in it and they need to see
something different are you kidding
so like this is about the the word of
the day is in perpetuity words pictures
and videos in perpetuity never stops and
by life but like just even looking at
you this is not a joke yeah maybe you
over-index with urban right and maybe
you need somebody else making videos and
and I would love to know like how many
homes is the is the wife or the woman
the decision-maker she's gonna need
different [ __ ] yeah like he can't make a
video so he'll bro but that's exactly
what you should do for 29 year old
single guy sure like this is the problem
with by the way back to America
everybody just wants it to be blue or
there's just a million different
variations that's how you actually do it
otherwise you know and so like you know
you can't say hey bro to a highly
liberal 29 year old in San Francisco
right so like all those things you know
that works for you in a maggot there are
subtleties within it right and then did
it did make sense
good good feedback I have one of the
question I asked this earlier but you
know we're at 80 people right now good
down there over two and a half years
it's a lot of growth you know you're at
800 something people now we took a
little tour this morning checked out
things you've been able to keep your
culture fire intact here fire is roll by
right and so we're hitting the stage now
in our organization where now there's
people come through the door that we're
two or three layers removed from me now
I don't know their name anymore I'm
seeing people that I'm like yo I
shouldn't know that I don't know that
guy anymore
more policies and procedures are good
too yep just think we're feeling that
happen how have you been able to grow
firing your agency like this and keep
that cloture firing yeah you're not
gonna know their names you're a human
being
you're gonna lose like I don't have the
relationship with number 202 number 800
that I do from 1 to 200 that's ok
guess what News Alert not all kids have
the same relationship with their parents
and there's only one or two or three
well two or three right like it just is
what it is like my parents love me more
than my brother and sister I was the
firstborn you know like it's just a lady
backs out here what I mean by that is
don't dwell on that and that crushed me
I took so much pride in that but that's
not a winnable game what is a winnable
game is firing the 80 people that are
the oh jeez the three of them within
that that don't like change are playing
politics no there's a you know when Ken
knows Sarah underneath him is more
talented than ken ken starts the process
of eliminating Sarah that's what you
have to look out for making sure the 50
oh geez the 20 most powerful people in
your company are playing for the logo
not for themselves I laughed watching my
most senior executives jockey for
themselves I'm on trickable on that and
they tonight sometimes I let them get
away with it for two years it's fine I'm
doing what's good for the logo but like
if you're not doing your time will come
here
individual people not not not people
that have already worn it on a flip more
actually um um both both yeah yeah no no
it's exactly
I love personal I want to tell you
something I love you because you're
right it's a good observation and it's a
great thing to be thinking about only
thinking about because it's a huge issue
and correct but that's my trying to
figure out wrap my head around what's
the direction because I'm about to put
money into renewing website and I'm
going
and Phil right to do it in a traditional
way I feel like it's like air B&B where
people want to sell their stuff and I
got to be the person coming up there's
two ways to do it there's two ways to do
it
you're being very smart let me throw two
things at you one yes here's your
problem if you decide to be a platform
instead of a retailer you need to make
sure you have a partner or a very senior
person that's super incentivized who has
platform DNA like I've watched people
all the time when I my hairs go up when
I hear I'm starting to build a tech
platform two years ago I'm oh this is
what smart entrepreneurs like you and I
do as a mistake the first time I did it
the first time you go into tech you
don't realize now you're in the tech
business and you need a tech partner not
somebody you hire to build it right so a
couple things that's one I'm gonna throw
you in a different place that I think is
super interesting to think about you're
right so now the question becomes the
other thing you could do which is
definitely more in tune to where I think
you could go because I think the first
way you'll have to make that big of a
decision which is okay let me start a
separate company with somebody you do a
50/50 JB and still have this so a
million ways you can go about it but the
way to combat what you're dealing with
is quadrupled down on brand I mean you'd
need to quadruple down on brand because
there will always be the person who you
even if it make people feel like no no
this is the one I have to buy like this
is the brand like that's the ultimate
like Nike is never real I cure always
worried you're scared you're being smart
but like like people gonna buy it like
you have to be the brand and so you have
to go from a utility this is what you
know it's funny back to your name you
know like all those people that built
websites that were so literal because
everybody cared about SEO and search and
so their company was called like you
know hardware tools Depot direct calm
the problem is once Google which is
where we're at now became mature and it
wasn't just about math and it was about
brand I know that so we're gonna go mope
get back to you like you know all of a
sudden they had to build a brand and
their brand being hardware store
utilities dot you Depot direct comm is
not a brand so
you have to triple down a brand and I
think we're representing a lot of brands
so our brand is like taking care of
those brands and pushing those brands
and getting it's more like taking care
of the person who needs it
well let's talk about that for a minute
so you as a retailer are selling other
brands yeah I mean we're we're doing a
consignment costume it might be a Weizen
it might be you know there's come true
it might be do you do do you have well
that's where you just bb2 so I would
quadruple down on your own brand like
quadruple if I was still running my
dad's wine business I would probably
take us to 35 percent private label and
I think they're probably out like two
percent right now it's the only place
you can go in the long tail of the
internet because those brands you just
mentioned their strategy for the next
decade is to go direct and not have you
involved wherever they go yeah wherever
they go
we're I promise you they're gonna go is
direct-to-consumer oh yeah yeah why
would they give up the margin the
frictions been eliminated right so
that's what I think you have to do I
would highly recommend going heavy on
content around your own brands paying
influencers to wear your own brands put
your brand's you know you're probably
you have a cup you have multiple brands
that you're private labeling or one or
it's one brand good cuz it's the same
name so what would help me know well
when we originally saw you know we
thought you gotta go after skaters gotta
go to dancers you gotta go after you
about under-17 our function yep that's a
lot to manage yes so you know maybe that
wasn't the right strategy so we had
uncork
Peter from the costumes Chris look
mature for that you know overall stuff
and I'm part went under that and it's
kind of like are we confusing everybody
do we just pick one we just go Chris
Couture costumes but crystal Couture
costumes is a retailer that consigns
other sub brands right I'm saying you
need to create a brand and call it like
yes like when you go to Crystal Couture
you know calm like the feature dress is
brought to you by a brand named dolly
doll and that's you own that brand and
you try to make dolly doll Nike yeah and
I guess we do that to a certain extent
because all the consignment stuff is
undergone [ __ ] and then we have couture
designer when you say 'under are those
are separate coms or when you land on
the website it's separate that comes
that have the same website I say with
costumes and one and we lead with our
other stuff I say I think you should
visit common if I if I bought your into
your company we became partners our
first meaning would look like this I
think we should create a brand like hey
Swiss like a not like a like a brand and
make a great [ __ ] dress or costumes
or whatever it is and [ __ ] market the
[ __ ] out of it you know it's the
evolution from going from retail like to
going to being the product because
that's what the Internet's gonna force
yeah one way or another you know cool
you're welcome well I'm
we we dominate the inventory on our on
our business and I want to upscale my
business to some things that we don't
have tell me what you're dominating and
tell me examples of ideologically what
you would like to what we dominate what
does that mean like what
give me literally like a dump truck how
much is a concrete pump from $80 to how
much not 8,000 yeah to 500,000 right and
how much do you buy them for 10 bucks
if are you are and the reason you're
able to find them like just in that
world how are you how are you marketing
or what's the funnel or why are you why
did you guys get great at it is it
social media ads is it direct mail is it
phone calls is it knocking on doors like
what is it
well it's prodding them at when you know
in Mexico yeah they don't manufacture
the kind of equipment yes so they're in
a construction company they're always
looking for
and equipment so we started advertising
and medical unit which is a Bey in
Mexico and their website and that's how
we first started selling art well it's
on now
Carlos you go to auctions to pick them
up right we do we do a stamina the
appetite for the market and the way the
way we started our business model was
okay we started doing like a lot of
dealers you know starting helping them
with their old equipment that they
wouldn't take in right yeah sadly like
David will take your junk
we'll buy it yeah buy for cheap and and
you know take some money way to do
better do the new equipment and that's
how our strategy love that yeah and we
came upon me there they started
financing another you Clementine take it
in 90 days I understand so what do you
what do you want to sell now I want to
sell them and I'd like that I don't have
I want to open the umbrella our
customers say okay we don't have this on
the inventory okay but we have a notch
and that we're gonna participate in this
what's gonna come out
are you interested
and I want to want to I want to get
customers to feel comfortable shopping
what we don't have I understand right
well I think you can't feel ready yeah
so I think I well can they feel and
touch the other stuff cuz they come
somewhere physically or they watch
looking at it online well first of all
they contacted phone via phone and then
if we get some interest
they'll fly in because we sell our
marketers nationwide
right don't fly into the knows airport
put them up and then they'll get a
feeling of the equipment right now I
mean there's only one way cuz that
people have ever sold anything that they
don't own and they want to make a money
on the float on the arbitrage of what
they know they could pay for it and
being bidding for it
it's it's only been done based on
building trust around the brand there's
nothing else and there's a what's really
amazing about today's world is like I
think you take a little bit out of what
he does and what I do I think you make
collateral videos like like and put
yourself out there and be like how long
have you been in business
right like I've been doing this for five
years owning this business you can say
whatever hell you were doing before then
you know you know you there's a lot of
things you can do I mean like you know
you can put money into escrow like you
just chip away like there is no magic
pill you need to make the first 50
people feel comfortable and be
aggressive at it I mean I mean you could
put up you could have the person put up
the money in escrow like there's a lot
you could do you could personally
guarantee it
like any time I'm doing something that
may feel weird I'm always comfortable
doing anything because I know I'm not
gonna rip them off like you know like
you you should do things for the first
50 people that you won't do for the
fifty first person too many people go
ideological I want to figure out the
entire business model on the first
transaction got it
so all you need to do is have examples
right one you know and guadeloupe
trusted me and he got it right and what
you don't have to tell the world is like
and I put up all the money on escrow too
just to make him feel very comes to you
know what I mean whatever it may be but
you I mean that's just the way it is
this is
no different than when I tell people do
[ __ ] for free at first like well Gary
I'm work for five thousand dollars an
hour I'm like says who
if you work for five thousand an hour
you should be getting lots of hours and
getting paid but it doesn't look like
like the market decides so I think if to
build trust create less risk and you see
right and you can do a million different
things I don't know your cash flow like
you know there's a million ways to do it
maybe for the first time ever you open a
credit line to help you do the first
move like there's a million ways to do
as long as you know you're not gonna
take somebody's [ __ ] money and run
off right I always tell people like if
you're on the right side of your intent
you should over deliver for the first
customers because your your interests
are aligned you're trying to you're
trying to create examples for other
people to trust you and so thus you're
willing to go further you know
financially or credit or sign something
you would never normally sign I do it
all the time to this day so I mean you
know with k-swiss or with HarperCollins
I mean with what it's funny to see the
snakes or something it's really funny I
don't remember but either my last case
with steal or my last book deal
basically I was on the hook like I had
to hit it and basically I just said to
myself learn just buy them and give them
away if I have to like I'm not gonna
screw the partner right I'm not gonna be
happy I'll lose money but but I wanted
the example
how do we build our budget for marketing
icon Facebook on social media huh how
you take that number you guess you guess
with a number that you feel great about
if it goes to zero so if that's ten
thousand bucks and it goes to zero you
learned what can you afford to lose you
know on Facebook for me at this moment
and all of you know what I feel about it
what can you afford to lose but it comes
into making remember the biggest reason
people lose on Facebook is they make one
piece of content and they target broad
got it that's the reason people lose on
Facebook one piece of content and target
broad because they act like a big
company I'm gonna make a commercial and
I'm gonna target 18 to 35 year old dudes
that's my favorite part
has anybody ever met an 18 year old and
35 that are super they're so not
different like just by common sense an
18 year old guy in a 35 year old are two
[ __ ] different dudes yeah yes of
course you lived it you know exactly
what kind of [ __ ] idiot you were at
18
the one-piece content you put out that
hit me was the thing like a media
company hmm
I'm a media company taxes on fuels I
love you um trying what happened when
you started make when you made that
switch what happened I decided I had to
kind of go all-in Facebook I said okay
we need an actual we already now 14
person company as of a year ago we were
like a 10 person already so you added
those kind of people who don't like yeah
and did you also go more into content do
you go more into the TV show versus the
commercial because that's what happens
right when you understand you're not
you're selling by doing brand you go
from being QVC to being Game of Thrones
you do blogging inside stuff like that
you're down my marketing department
great news is I'm also the marketing
department so I got to tell you what to
do good love that the so we're doing a
facebook Q&A Q&A live session for an
hour and a half first Friday of every
month we take each individual question
chop it up have content with the whole
month we take those long tail yes idols
yes Google
yes mr. about the audio for podcasts yes
and the montemagno we're actually
putting a second story on our building
to basically house a television studio
and expand the question is we're doing a
we're going to be redoing the website
right now it's a strictly ecommerce
website and we have a bunch little toys
for the customers to play with the
design error like that mm-hmm
tour and walk around the the question is
should I leave the media stuff all the
free content and putting out live on
YouTube when everywhere else and then
have our e-commerce site of a black hole
or like people just come there to shop
period or should I try to be post feeds
or embed Beauty I understand we say
product but not going to step up on
there both will work I think when people
open the can of worms of deeply
integrating all this media into their
web sites
it gets convoluted and they get that
most people suck at integrating content
you
to their websites for commerce so I'm
very comfortable in you not even though
you have all that collateral because
it's really like let's play it out one
more time
Nike markets and then you go into a
store and buy it there is that
separation I'm not against it
I'm also not against you having a little
bit there I probably I'd be more excited
being a product page level content play
than a landing page level content play
see what I mean uh-huh that's why I
think excuse me I'm sorry
oh yeah that's what I think we're
teaching but it is a scary kind of
concept for your a guy - yeah what why
do people do it there is period yeah
[ __ ] knew it
anybody else no I get it I get it
there's like there's a lot of
subcultures in it
the main the bagpipers not gonna stuff
piled athletes the main one is Karadzic
oh so the question I have is we're kind
of thinking about other types of content
to put out of yo for video do would it
be a good idea or two cookie to do a
invite customer in and say okay I'm
gonna record an entire package sale
soup-to-nuts where I gave little hints
and tips and tricks during the entire
process and I'm not a Salesman it's more
like okay tell me your budget I want to
maximize what you can get and the
versatility within that I'm not trying
to you know squeeze every penny out
would that come off do you think as to
sales pitchy or would it kind of like no
I think it's like a fear I think it
would do a couple things one I think it
would open up a different world to you
where people would look to you more as
like a business and sales guy which
could lead to certain things
look I think intent trumps everything so
like I'm not worried about it being too
salesy if the intent is it to not be too
salesy you know I think the interesting
part is like going deeper into the four
or five biggest subcultures and making
sure you're creating enough content for
them cuz heritage makes so much sense
and feels like felt like to me is like
damn that's got to be the business but
when you start talking about other
subcultures demographics psychographics
you know you know sexualities things of
that nature
you want to make sure you have enough
content filling those pipes yes I'm very
aware about of America I would run at
first of all even if you didn't have the
political undertones that we have today
you shouldn't do it because it won't
convert and the media is underpriced see
Google's not underpriced anymore it's
properly priced that's why it has a
different strategy in facebook when it's
underpriced know you you run hat which
is the right way to do it period on
Facebook because organic Reach is super
low anyway but the ads are under priced
so the people that got are losing on
Facebook are emotional that the organic
reach is down so they're checked out
meanwhile the ads are under priced cool
first off got it man I love watching you
think how you go so quickly from being
in your head back to your heart going
through your experience that transition
you look up thanks fascinated a lot from
the psychological aspect of things two
part question one part about finding
talent another one about developing
marketing aspects of the businesses all
three of my businesses are the same
business they're just doing different
jobs hire seven or eight originally
started off with me being the brand that
was the face I was giving my what do you
Wednesday videos question answers all
these things be in any personal personal
interaction the rest of my team is get
left behind because I'm the face of
brand everyone wants to go to a while
later let's go see you later now I gotta
start going okay
go see my specialist gonna see my
specialist than that my talent pool my
industries are very small in New York
State we graduate maybe 200 that come
first every year now that's not 200 good
acupuncture's is probably three or four
that are good how many actually have the
cloud at Christmas characters ticks that
heartfelt compassionate desire to grow
that don't want to do in their own tried
leveraging the schools of UVA first
opportunity top five grads immediate
without a job placement trial one in six
months they want to be a company teach
about I don't want to leverage my time
teaching them that downplay or do i well
I think you know first of all I haven't
listened to enough yet but very quickly
when one I want to make sure that it's
not your ego that's making the pool
small but if let's say you're right and
that pool is that small and even to your
point even if it wasn't ego and all 200
we're good that's still not the biggest
pool in the world I think I liked the
fact that you ended your sentence with
or do I because it's almost like as
you're asking a question you realize
[ __ ] if my vulnerability is this thing
then yes there's a lot of things maybe
I'd rather be doing but there might not
be anything more valuable than my time
on that because I'm in the vulnerability
of that pool there's a bigger question
which is even if you got the top three
every year you know employees by nature
are always a vulnerability when you're
at the vulnerability of an employee
skill set so
the model becomes the thing you have to
scrutinize it I get it yeah keep on
practice been around now for about five
years
pretty much soft with Highness it's
rolling on its only if I take a step
back into the six months kind of step
back to see where yeah a smart vision
and three months of started dropping and
when you say at the forefront consumer
facing or back of the house operations
both the three companies one more time
acupuncturist yep and do all three
companies sit under one LLC and his
anybody have any equity in the
individuals got it
understood I mean look when you know
back to what you deal with by you know
you rodeo like you know when you have
too many ideas like it's all about
having people in place that can execute
and an understanding what their
incentives are do I hire people will be
funds for that do I hire locators which
we gotta do I can't be diploma camera
doctors well I think one thing that you
need yeah there's a couple things to
think about number one you know like
building personal brands as the
marketing play is only something that
people are paying attention to now
because it's hit the zeitgeist but it's
not the right answer all the time like I
don't know MetLife doesn't use the CEO
of MetLife they use snoopy right like
like you know so I look I think it's a
very first a lot of people stumbled into
it there's what's going on on Instagram
which natively makes it about that more
so than other platforms I there's a lot
of ways you could do it like to your
point like you can hire people that want
to do it or you can start thinking about
building it more about the brand and
making the marketing about the brand and
the brand promise Equinox doesn't have
Ernie Equinox in their content so when
when you say camera just to be able to
do something so he stole your d-roc busy
yeah it's good kids great yeah do you
want me to steal the Jason's like video
kit do you want me to steal Jason I'm
just gonna get him just for fun just to
settle the score
get me Jason's info get me Jason's info
I'm literally gonna steal Jason it's
just one big meta thing you come to
fourth you come to four DS if Jason just
moves around you don't you don't the
reason I win a lot with people who are
either celebrities or on their first day
when I help them when if I have time to
talk to them is because I realized
something a long time ago which is you
can't force people to do things they
don't want to do and expect success
there's a very specific reason my report
card looked like it did this morning
when I posted it like you're not gonna
force me to do that and more importantly
you don't want to waste the energy
convince them I believe you are I
believe it so you either a now hire
going forward we're the upfront promises
this is a disproportionate video
recording environment and and by the way
if you were the personal brand put this
out here's what I would do in the
what you make a face front-facing video
and Internet and saying I'm hiring
practitioners in this craft that love
being on camera as well because that is
my macro thesis for my business two
things are gonna happen
you'll get deal flow the people that
work for you now may actually raise
their hand and say you know what changed
my mind
I'm gonna take that camera yeah an
amazing thing happens an amazing thing
happens when when you put pressure in
real life not in thesis or words yeah
they're gonna see that video and then be
like they're gonna decide if they want
to be there or not and some people might
not give a [ __ ] and be like cool let's
see him hire somebody better that
[ __ ] whatever crap than me and then
you do and then the police out I would
definitely definitely do that what's up
100% and here's the good news we're
going through this at Vayner right now
looking James and Mark like we had this
big meeting and I was like like in the
beginning in the end I was like look I'm
changing the direction of our creative
output and their strategic and creative
output and it's super okay if you don't
agree with me because I know it's fairly
rogue and so like come and see me and
I'll get you a job doing what you want
to do for more money somewhere out this
doesn't have to be bad back to personnel
I don't want bad I just don't want to go
to business I'm definitely I'm in charge
of running the business so I'm going to
change the direction and you know you're
a hockey player I just we've been
playing hockey and now I'm saying we're
playing basketball not everybody's gonna
transfer that skill and that's okay
and I think that's what you do you know
it's okay that they don't want to you
just know it's super important for your
business and you're gonna do it that I
definitely do it's also thinking that
you should also think that you should
definitely hire how are you running ads
who's running them
my buddy that's what he does with it got
it and you have any sense of he's good
or not yet and he loves to run quant ads
listen you know you've seen on video
what you've seen person you can't you
guys can't run enough Facebook and
Instagram ads now it's better that you
do it well you know but know that every
industry has a well for now because it's
so under priced there's nothing to tell
me from kilts to [ __ ] $800,000
[ __ ] drills they all exist there I
think I think LinkedIn is super
interesting I brought up earlier like I
think there's a version of that there
too and there's you can and again this
is back to psychographics so it's you
know a Magga or an extreme liberal are
different on facebook than they are on
LinkedIn you know you guys hung out a
little bit last night right like it's a
different vibe than this is this we're
in an office we're having a bubble you
know you got it you have business talk
last night but it's a little more casual
a little more tequila right like like
you know and so the context of the room
really matters and so all of a sudden
the video you put on linked it like we
we are starting to get mature I'm
looking at Caleb now on my team you know
like we're starting to get mature about
like okay like you know for example I
mean you guys know I'm so respected by
my fanbase of like and he hasn't wavered
and he isn't hearse he continues to
curse he hasn't stopped even though but
meanwhile it's just black and white
obvious to me that I could be much
further along on LinkedIn if I just add
beeps and guess what
[ __ ] beeps like it's not super
complicated
trying to win out here in like you know
LinkedIn's an environment psychology
why's that
there is dramatically more qualitative
feedback in the comments of like this
guy curses I loved what he had to say
but I'll never listen to him again and
listen I don't have the audacity to
enforce my will like I'm gonna be me as
a human I'm not gonna stop cursing
but in post-production we'll get a
[ __ ] beep got it yeah so I I do think
that um I do think you have to you know
what here's what stop for entrepreneurs
is turning into executives it's rough
and so it's about trust it's about
eliminating ego
it's about being really good at firing
when you make the wrong call what's
really hard especially your compassion
empathetic person it does get easier
nice to stay on things for two years now
there's six months see you know but they
should be one month and that's just the
truth so yes so a lot of work we've had
some I think epiphanies over the last
year where we start to see more and more
as the content and it's and it's quiet
and it's quietly all sales driven but
even the people that try to fake it and
like show something if you like sniff it
you're like that's a sales yeah it's
like free consultations [ __ ] you you
know like yeah you know what I mean
though it works
ya know but you know what I mean like
like it is but like you know what I mean
percent so basically what happened is in
about May we started to look at the
content right we're producing ebooks
we're a consulting firm so what do we do
you look at don't wait don't you produce
these thoughts yeah yeah then we look at
engagement right and so we put this GDP
our ego right yeah it's [ __ ] right
yes so good the engagement terrible
right terrible everyone downloading it's
all middles funnel people anyway people
are the inner pipeline or really to new
people so like start listening to you
right and started to realize like wait
I'm not scaled I think that was part of
it too we're a consulting company I
started the company at first when I
started it I didn't name it Dunlap
consulting because I wanted to say hey
learn to build a company or build a
brand right but what I've realized over
time is maybe that was wrong right and
so it was wrong because it was the
proper point of view of many in a world
that doesn't exist anymore right
the Internet is a much bigger thing than
people realize and so to your point
where you went to was like
right I was playing under rules of a
yesterday right keep going exactly right
right and I wanted to build if you look
at like our consulting room you've got
the beasts and you got ones in Tuesday's
yes and I always wanted to build a
comedy right - yelling to try to build
some lifestyle yeah
in May we just said all right we'll [ __ ]
it I'll just start posting myself on
LinkedIn text-based posts just talking
about the things that we're doing I
think we were I was always very hesitant
I'd push everything to scale scaled is
doing these things scaled is doing these
things and instead it started to talk
about the things I was doing and then by
you know people figured it out and I
think we've started to see at least a
path word for me on LinkedIn right
talking about make sense got lots of
posts that are getting make sense
hundreds of thousands of views thousands
of likes so we're starts here out it's
great to figure out some things there
are you running paid only thing yet
because it's got that floor pricing and
it feels expensive yeah but you can get
super narrow yeah I think about it you
can you can target an HR director in the
concrete industry like like you know
there's a reason it's $55 CPM like you
can get to like you know how great in a
b2b world knowing the title the person
that's seeing it is
you mean perfect yeah something you
should a hundred percent test yeah
like tomorrow because again and here's
how it works is where people [ __ ] up pay
attention for some of you if you've
decided we haven't tapped into st. Louis
business I'm making [ __ ] up now in the
insurance space the opening video right
you know we're about to go hey st. Louis
insurance dealers it's me Dunlap let's
go like you know like if you can't
imagine what those first three second
speed and you can't imagine when you
make the video after you know who you're
targeting yeah yeah I think the other
piece was trying to figure out is
Facebook and Instagram right for b2b
right so we are a sales consulting firm
real quick thinking about that don't
like one of the things that's really
bothering me is you don't have to do
everything you don't have you don't have
to win on Instagram the watching
everybody try to win on Instagram mainly
because it's the most culturally
important platform and they're really
doing it because they want to be
cool in real life not for business is
like the funniest thing I'm watching
it's not like I'm like you don't need to
win on Instagram just run Facebook or it
LinkedIn or whatever it may be but
they're doing it because it's so
cultural and they want to have 5,000
followers but it doesn't like yeah but
but this is this is why I keep this why
I have to keep like like I look I think
you can ironically win on Instagram it's
so [ __ ] cheap that it is worth it
the truth is though you have to squeeze
the [ __ ] out of the thing that's obvious
before you can even begin to think about
the rest let me give you one that will
work for all of you I don't know if
anybody here has started running
pre-roll YouTube ads based on Google
search queries but that's incredible
actually can somebody do me a favor
Chanel can you go ask the media team
what the exact terminology is around
that can you go ask Garen like to find
out I don't I always say the literal I
don't know what Google is calling it
it's when you are able to run pre-roll
on YouTube based on people's search
behavior so like literally people
searching for I'm like consulting help
from my account it looks like buying
like people are searching buying a drill
and then then that same person is going
and watching soccer videos but then you
show up and be like hey are you in the
market for a grill and he's like oh [ __ ]
I am how do you know it's like spooky
[ __ ] like that spooky ship is based on
that that's the best one that and the
people that did well on Facebook video
and they make that under strike so it's
the intent based video brand based so
think about all right you see where I'm
going so mom's going to watch like a
like a clip from her favorite show last
night but you pre-roll in and 30 days
ago she was searching dresses it's a
great product what are some of the macro
trends you see it B to C that are going
to infiltrate in a bet I'll answer you
in a different way that I think is
really what you're asking I would
heavily lean into HR dynamics sales
teams are vulnerable because of human
things you will win SAS sales people if
you made a video of why you should fire
your top salesman it will
viral little cross crush yeah and it
starts like this your top salesman he or
she's a dick and it's making everybody
else suck and you're [ __ ] letting him
and her get away with it
because you like the numbers they're
bringing in but they're destroying your
[ __ ] company let me save you time
that is 97% of SAS companies problem
right now that [ __ ] will go Phil let me
tell you what happens with that video
you target that video to HR executives
on LinkedIn and pay their high Vig if
she or he has the juiced any
organization you're gonna get a lot of
[ __ ] business yeah because they're
sitting right now pissed because they
know it's a vulnerability and your video
is gonna give them the oomph to go into
the CFO's office and say this game's
over
Sarah CFO I'm done we're firing John
tomorrow so human truths is the number
one whitespace in sales right now
we're seeing that I see it we've
unlinked it killing it we see it too now
what I'll tell you is don't like so I've
see it too we see it on our LinkedIn but
we're still doing more video here's why
don't just pander to the platform's
algorithms if your currency is you know
getting more views what a video does is
it builds more brand right got it
so I'm losing the LinkedIn algorithm but
I'm establishing more brand and I'm
willing and I mix it up so don't just
become one-dimensional on what's working
there's so much of that going in on
LinkedIn right now people are scared to
try new things because certain things
are working right now I'm getting the
least kind of stuff that I like
engagement and views for the last two
weeks after the best week I had because
off the momentum of the look the best
week I had I said you know what I'm
gonna [ __ ] take my own advice I'm
gonna I'm on a roll right now in every
videos getting a million views let me
put up stuff intuitively that I don't
think will do well to learn from and it
hasn't done well but the little lemonade
clip did super well and that wouldn't
have been something I put up before
because I just fun light-hearted not
what I do I'm like okay the human stuff
got to think about bad
opened up a new concept so you see what
I'm doing like as soon as something
works for me I try to destroy it and
what most people do is they become
vulnerable to it right that something
works and they lean all-in right and
what I do is I never let something have
too much less I will never die because
Google slow down I will never let
snapchat destroy me I will never let
Twitter I'm so diversified right
written audio video first in line my own
CRM
I've got your text numbers I've got your
email email text you've got it I bring
top I bring I bring top of the funnel
awareness to the agency a lot of people
don't want to work with vaynermedia
because they don't like me and a lot of
people want to work with vaynermedia cuz
they like me but then that's better than
not doing it audio I would start a
podcast yesterday yeah
audio matters and what's really great
about audio is you can have some of the
other team transcribe the audio and make
it written content for you on LinkedIn
the [ __ ] did you see the deck the 80
the gap yeah you will you need to look
at it part it's you can Google right now
Gary to be content Decker a note
something you're well on your way now
let me I can just let me tell you the
real answer you're looking for more it
will go away did you do Google AdWords
in 2003 when he started yes 2005 five
six yeah crazy stuff right yeah not as
good as it is now the end see that
reaction for part yeah it will go away
it will go away because everybody on
earth is gonna do social media which is
gonna raise the prices so you got
something that's the reason I've
exploded last 18 months I had that
conversation myself I'm like okay I
talked about publicly regretting that my
dad's liquor store wasn't 200 million
because I didn't run enough Google Ads
I'm about to do the same [ __ ] mistake
I'm at the top of my game
in the thing
I'm gonna [ __ ] be pissed so [ __ ] it
let's go from four to 20 people let's
[ __ ] go all in let me be it and you
guys at you know I don't know how long
you guys been following but the last two
years are very different than the years
before that fun industry dance
competition yes everyone's kind of all
about it in our kind of world
b2b average ticket 2250 grand average
take a twenty fifty grand really
competitions we don't take our money
from like the dance from the parents we
go to the dance studio so that's kind of
like where you enable a dance studio to
be in the dance competition business
correct like them paying you 20 to 50
grand to compete correct to compare
henan events
cuz the studio enters correct I say and
then they do whatever they do underneath
right whatever the [ __ ] they're into
that make a big not make a big whatever
okay from there so we're an advanced
based company about 180 events so right
now our social is mostly just for the
kids we really don't have a strategy to
say hey some of of dance studio come
register with us it's mostly just
entertainment good right so which how
many dance studios are there there's so
just in our database about 10,000 love
ideas I'm gonna give you an answer that
I think is a be idea for you but an a be
for everybody else that I haven't gotten
to and I'll give you some others using
Facebook and LinkedIn to create
in-person events is unbelievable
and I know that would make sense to you
and it's gonna make like sense to you
new my favorite thing in a new
neighborhood and the clearly in sales I
would use wine because it's authentic to
me there's also golf there's also other
things those two are really really good
but running ads that say you know just
back to prospecting I'm hosting a dinner
at this country club or I'm putting on
this up the and you go macro so let's
use an example and everybody will take
it from here
you pick an area where there's a lot of
dance studios so you can run ads at a
lower cost and you'd say hey Phoenix I'm
we're host ands videos very authentic
back to like Pete and from the camera
you're like
I'm gonna be in Phoenix we rented out a
wonderful room in your awesome steak
house Johnny Steakhouse I saw the great
Yelp reviews I've been wanting to go
there
got some nice food and wine and we're
gonna be putting on a 20-person dinner
where we're gonna talk the State of the
Union of dance studios opportunities in
social media how to make more margin
what's happening in the macro trends how
the TV shows have affected us what's
happened last 15 years I've been in the
family business for my family's been
numerous for 35 years I've been running
it for 15 da-da-da-dah please fill out
the form and I will pick 20 of you can't
wait to see you on November 19th at 8:00
p.m. that's your video the the copy has
all the information and has a link it's
a Google form the Google form has
questions one of the questions first
it's like name studio revenue employees
whatever the [ __ ] but one is a
open-ended question where they have to
answer it that will give you insight if
you think you can convert them you pet
you spend you know 500 bucks on the
Facebook ads you pick up a thousand
dollar tab at the end of the night and
for 1500 all in you've got a captive
audience where you're the host of I call
it the high school party concept right
like whoever was the high school kid
whose parents traveled a lot or didn't
give a [ __ ] that was able to host the
parties coolness grew dramatically
because they hosted the party so like
you watched a lot of people be nerdy
freshman year and then become popular
because they figured it out and they
their basement was in play so the cool
kids needed it so they by osmosis got a
little cooler and the worst versions are
they woke up and realized they were
taking advantage up and the best
versions as it worked out right so like
but that was it right no that's what I
want a lot of you to do I want you to
host the event in a b2b environment or
high-ticket b2c yeah see what I'm going
yeah that will work
it's superhuman it's incredible
networking the people that are gonna
sign up for it or exactly right like
they've got to take time to fill out the
form but like your personality can shine
through be like a what's the worst that
can happen you can get a free meal like
you know it's really fun it will really
work it will really work and then again
everybody here is their own person
there's some unique things like me
you know come and learn how to rodeo
maybe somebody here is great at tennis
and that's what they want to do like
like as simple as like this where I want
you to have interpretation keyword
targeting within Adwords
because you can just you - yep cool
maybe when Garin comes in there right
now we could show like the URL that
explains it okay Norris Nourse again if
you're a great tennis player and your
concept interpretation of what I just
said is doing something called like
doubles Tuesdays and every Tuesday you
find three people and you're one partner
with one you know like bu but the most
simple like white-label one is just like
here's a dinner on the state of the
union of our industry and all you are is
a curator like maybe one of the things
is like what do you want to cover like
you see you don't do anything like 20
people have filled out what what
question do you want asked and room good
you take the 15 you know you literally
like all right first question where
everybody how come mortgages are going
up like it's the easiest thing to do see
where I'm going
don't even have to create the content
the other one is paying influencers but
they also compete so it's like trying to
stay neutral a neutral yeah which has
been a hard one because we had one
influencer who she was killing it on our
views and just she was reposting she was
commenting and it was going great till
she also won like and then all of a
sudden it's like you won because of I
think that's a vulnerability for you
yeah I don't think you should I think
retired players players that aren't in
it but yeah I do think that's a
vulnerability that you don't need right
I just would not I would just like take
that very seriously yeah and then the
last question I have is kind of just
posting so we have content we don't lack
content dancers you have unlimited
content photos and videos galore you
have unlimited content what you need is
a post-production machine that creates
contextual content so with that is all
the music that the dancers are choosing
our
popular songs yeah and it gets second
now yeah where we get dinged on YouTube
for it or we go mute on Facebook so
right now we've been going to heavy on
story cuz really take it down because
short period of time yeah yeah any
suggestions on workarounds for that or
the rules are the rules just go for it
you know you could put up stuff and just
wait to it comes down yeah he's kind of
what we're doing you could do stories
you know you're doing the right stuff
there house here's what I would say back
to the thesis I want to leave you with
when there's a cute little asian girl
dancing that clip should be targeted to
Asian parents you have unlimited content
thus you should be the last person that
isn't doing contextual creative at scale
yeah got it I mean it's just it's the
craziest thing like be et over indexes
with African American viewers cuz
they're in it like who watches Tula
mundo like you know like like we have to
become marketers like that right content
at scale ads you know what you're
targeting with your money then you make
the content and most people make the
content and run ass got it we are under
indexing with sass products around
finance now I'm gonna make content we
are not winning with 400,000 everything
let's think about every cliche we can
think of how much behind or on time
24 hours a moment it depends on what
your metric is to Nick in the breath it
depends on what your book - once the
Nick wants to Brad yeah it depends what
your metric is if he's trying to sell
kilts he's gonna [ __ ] know within 24
or 48 hours is gonna watch it but I've
been convert any ads if you're trying to
build brand you're looking for
engagement qualitative engagement I like
this guy I hate this you know like right
what are you looking for making bread to
make another one - bread
yeah that's gonna be hard I don't do it
- yeah not cool you know what I mean it
always depends like it's a very weird
vert it's the micro version of the macro
answer I gave him winning is happy not
making more money because you focused
only on the tech company the fulfillment
like well you know you know like what
what are you trying to accomplish and by
the way it's okay if that [ __ ] changes
you know 27 you might need money or a
boyfriend or a girlfriend at 34 you
might want to have more white
light/white work-life balance cuz you
have a child now at 41 you might need
more money because you wasted your money
after you had a good like it's okay for
it to change daily
you